das ist ein konsolenklick bald ist es spaß
kunden warum geändert ich mache
es kam auch von alkohol weil shake 20
je jason statham zum interview und
jay-z
wie geht es den dingen die dinge sind gut
ja sehr gut nein wirklich nicht
Essbare Reise nach Berlin Es ist eine kurze
Reise, weißt du, nur eine Nacht, leider,
aber wir sind gerade nach Moskau gefahren, also ist es
Jahre und Jahre her, seit ich dort war
, weißt du, wir versuchen nur, ein
paar Orte zu sehen, die wir noch nie gesehen haben  siehe mmm
und ein paar Fragen, dein Charakter ist eine
Art moderner Robin Hood, nimm es einfach
von den Reichen oder von denen,
die es verdienen,
wie kannst du dich ein
bisschen mit Parker
identifizieren?  Parker, wissen Sie
, das sind Charaktere, über die
geschrieben wurde, und besonders dieser
Charakter, über den er in 24 verschiedenen
Romanen von einem sehr berühmten Autor namens
Donald Westlake geschrieben wurde, also gibt es Leute wie
Lee Marvin, die diesen
Charakter vor Mel Gibson gespielt haben
2012 ist meine Zeit, in der ich
Gibson wegen der Geburt der Person
Plug Day gespielt
habe  etwas recherchieren
und ein paar Banken ausrauben, und Sie wissen, dass Sie
versuchen können, sich selbst
bestmöglich als diese Person vorzustellen, und der Rest
ist Ihre eigene Interpretation und
die Interpretation der Geschichte des Regisseurs, so
okay, dass Sie es gewohnt sind, mit sehr zu drehen  sehr
heiße Frauen, aber vor allem war es etwas
Besonderes, einen Film mit einer Jennifer
Lopez zu machen  eine Seite von ihr
, die auf einer Arbeitsebene, wo Sie
wissen, dass beide auftauchen, um die gleiche Art
von Arbeit zu erledigen, also wissen Sie, dass sie ein sehr, sehr,
sehr süßes Mädchen ist und sich gerne an uns erfreut.
Ich denke, wir sind da, Sie wissen, wir hatten
eine  tolle Zeit, diese Datei zu machen  m und
ich denke, es liegt daran, dass Sie wissen, ob
Sie eine gute Chemie haben oder nicht, also wissen Sie,
dass wir Synchronisation haben und
Deutschland, also haben Sie jemals diesen
Deutschen Jason Stefan gehört?
Nein, ich würde gerne hören, was Sie
über diese Art von Synchronisation denken
Weil die nicht-ohmschen Deutschen
deine wahre Stimme nicht kennen, kennen sie meine
Stimme nicht. Ich denke, er ist ziemlich lustig. Es gab
eine Geschichte, in der wir vor nicht allzu langer Zeit in Spanien waren,
und es gibt eine bestimmte
Synchronisationsstimme, die
Sylvester Stallones aufgenommen hat  Stimme für
Sie wissen, die letzten 25 Jahre und dieser Typ
war sehr, sehr krank und wurde ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert
und konnte den neuesten
Film nicht aufnehmen, also wussten sie nicht, was sie tun sollten,
weil sie ein Veröffentlichungsdatum hatten, also werden diese
besonderen Dinge mehr  So
berühmt oder genauso wichtig in diesen
Ländern wie sie sind, wie die Schauspieler
, die die Rollen spielen, irgendwie darin, die
Stimme in Deutschland zu finden, ist sehr okay, also ist es
wahrscheinlich besser, ja, ja, ich werde
kommen und meinen englischen Film machen  Ich
danke dir